hello everyone thanks for joining us my
name is Kabir Kushner I'm a faculty at
the Yale School of Public Health I'm the
faculty director for humanitarian
research lab at our school of Public
Health
and I've had the pleasure of knowing
Professor Claire Greene
long time ago and she was a student an
mph student at our school of Public
Health
Professor Claire Greene is an assistant
professor in the program on forced
migration and health at Columbia
University mailman School of Public
Health
she received her PhD in psychiatric and
substance use epidemiology from Johns
Hopkins Bloomberg School of Public
Health and as I said she got her mph
from our School of Public Health in the
chronic disease EPI and Global health
department and she did her postdoctoral
training and implementation science and
humanitarian Health from Colombia
at Columbia she teaches courses on the
collection analysis and use of data to
improve humanitarian assistance and on
mental health and forced migration her
research focuses on designing and
evaluating strategies for improving the
effectiveness and implementation of
mental health and substance use
intervention in humanitarian settings
in addition to her research and teaching
she regularly consults for human
agencies and humanitarian ngos on the
design and evaluation of mental health
and substance abuse program
thank you so much Claire for joining us
I'll pass it on to you
truly a pleasure
pleasure to be here today so as coffee
mentioned I it feels very good to be
back here so I did my mph here at Yale
and I have so many wonderful memories of
my time here one of them being a photo
is at the top left of your screen I did
my thesis research under the supervision
of Professor Trace Kershaw and through
the Downs Fellowship which was led at
the time by cave in China focused on
mental health and substance use and HIV
and the photo just below the on the
bottom left hand side of the screen is
actually my mph thesis poster
presentation which my parents were so
proud of that they actually framed it
and it's been hanging in their basement
for over 10 years now so I guess I have
a big thank you to Yale for helping me
make my parents proud but in all
seriousness it's really a pleasure to be
back here such fond memories and really
Yale is where I discovered the fields of
humanitarian health and mental health in
their intersection and I worked with a
postdoc at the MacMillan Center on a
review trying to understand the
alignment of mental health interventions
that are implemented in practice and
those that are researched and perhaps
unsurprisingly the evidence we have does
not align very well or didn't align very
well with those interventions that are
actually implemented in practice and for
me this is really what sparked my
interest and motivated me to move along
this trajectory in mental health and
humanitarian settings which is one that
I'm still motivated and excited by today
so a big thanks to Yale and all of you
all right so I thought I'd start just by
talking about why you should care about
mental health in the context of
humanitarian settings Cafe and I were
just talking about how there's such a
plethora of Health needs in these
contexts but for me I think there are a
few reasons why mental health should
definitely be an essential part of
humanitarian assistance the first is
just thinking about the burden so the
best estimates we have suggest that 22
percent of people in Conflict affected
settings have a mental disorder that's
more than three times higher than the
general population
we know that even beyond that
people in humanitarian settings
experience elevated distress and that
affects their functioning and their
well-being so there's a lot of people
affected and who could benefit from
mental health and psychosocial supports
we also know that people in humanitarian
context have very limited access to
Services there are not a lot of
Specialists not a lot of mental health
providers fewer than 10 percent of
people in humanitarian settings with a
mental health problem access services
we also know that outside of the formal
Services System a lot of the community
and informal supports and protective
practices are disrupted in emergencies
and when people are displaced as well
which further increases the risk of
mental health issues
so I thought it would be helpful to
provide a little bit of a historical
context here
um because I think it highlights where
the field has been going and where we
are now and where we need to be going in
the future so it really wasn't until the
late 1980s that humanitarian actors
first convened at least on record to
discuss mental health needs in the
humanitarian context and this happened
in a refugee camp in Thailand with
refugees from Cambodia where according
to these humanitarian actors they
noticed a deteriorating social condition
that needed to be addressed within this
context
move forward one decade and we have the
first evidence of Psychosocial
interventions being applied in a
humanitarian setting in the context of
the conflict in the Balkans
and then it wasn't until 2007 to 2009
that we started to get guidelines and
really formalized recommendations around
how to respond to the mental health and
psychosocial needs in humanitarian
settings the publication of the
interagency standing committee
guidelines on mental health and
psychosocial support we also saw that
during this time unhcr added mental
health conditions to their list of kind
of the list of conditions they capture
as part of the health information system
prior to 2009 there was essentially no
record of people seeking support for
mental health through the primary care
system
and then in the 2010s we started getting
information and guidelines around how to
integrate mental health and cyber social
support which I'll start referring to as
mhpss because it's a mouthful across
different sectors in protection services
and Primary Care in other settings
so since 2010 there's really also been
this proliferation and research on
mental health or mhpss as you can see
here to the right these are the
Publications in PubMed that include
mental health and humanitarian settings
and you see this rapid increase after
about 2010 and the amount of research
being conducted on this topic
in parallel we've also seen the
development of various resources to
support the implementation of mhpss in
emergencies who has invested a lot in
developing these scalable psychological
interventions which are manualized
interventions evidence-based
interventions that can be delivered by
non-specialists in order to address that
Gap I mentioned between access to
specialized mental health providers in
these contexts
and I think the good news here is that
we have effective mental health
interventions this Forest plot on the
upper right hand side of the screen is
the result of or are the results from an
umbrella review or a systematic review
of reviews where they've essentially
found that in humanitarian settings we
have pretty good interventions that seem
to work particularly in adults to
address issues like depressive symptoms
anxiety symptoms post-traumatic stress
symptoms and distress
there's also been a lot of investment in
implementation science and trying to
understand how can we overcome some of
the barriers that exist to delivering
and accessing mental health and
psychosocial support in emergencies so
all of this is very good
but one of the things that I've been
thinking a lot about and that I think
motivates some of the work I'll share
with you today is why haven't we seen
this evidence really
being translated into population level
impact why is it not being adopted
within the humanitarian sector
and I think there are a few reasons why
we haven't yet seen kind of the
translation of this evidence into
improvements in population level
well-being
the first is that many of the
interventions we have there are effects
are short-lived so often we see that
people when they're in say a group based
intervention over eight weeks they tend
to improve but after that intervention
ends they often return toward maybe not
fully but regress a bit as far as their
mental health conditions
we also know that evidence-based
interventions are often not adopted or
sustained within routine services so a
lot of the evidence is generated within
the context of research and it's
challenging for various reasons to
actually integrate that into routine
care Delivery Systems
and then the third Point here which I
think is really Central to my talk today
is that many of these interventions
really do not consider the contextual
structural or social determinants of
mental health which we know are so
important to people's lived experience
and well-being
so this is why I present to you what I
think is the rationale for
multi-sectoral interventions and what I
mean by that is first we know that
mental health is a central part of
people's lived experience we also know
that it exists within the context of
many other factors and these are just a
list of of
um social and structural determinants of
health and mental health that we see in
the literature but also from some of our
formative work that relate to the mental
health and well-being of forcibly
displaced persons
but if we think about mental health is
operating in a vacuum by itself and
ignore these root causes and these risk
factors for mental health problems how
would we expect perhaps that the
intervention effects that we're trying
to to test can be sustained
so we did a survey with 225 Refugee and
migrant women in Ecuador and Panama
trying to understand what are the
factors of of your lived experience that
relate most strongly to your overall
well-being and life satisfaction
and what we essentially found was that
people's sense of safety and their
standard of living were most strongly
correlated with their overall well-being
and quality of life
probably isn't so surprising for many
people but what I think is important to
note is that these are not usually the
focus of our mental health and
psychosocial interventions often our
interventions are focused very much on
our thoughts and our feelings our
behaviors our interpersonal
relationships
but if really at the root of people's
well-being is their sense of safety and
protection and their standard of living
are we missing the mark by thinking kind
of too narrowly around what's happening
immediately in people's minds and in
their kind of immediate circles and
relationships
not to underwrite or discount those
they're important aspects of people's
well-being but I think what I'd like to
argue today is we need to think a bit
more broadly
and so part of that is
um
highlighted in this figure here so if
people if we're able to address people's
mental health with these interventions
that I've shown you that are effective
that people are operating and returning
to context where all of these risk
factors continue to be present can we
really expect that those mental health
effects will be long lasting
so I'd like to start today just with an
example of a study that we did a while
ago now that looked at this intersection
of intimate partner violence and mental
health in narrow gusu refugee camp in
Tanzania
so Niro Gusto is a refugee camp in
Western Tanzania that was established in
the mid-1990s at the time we started the
study in 2014 there were 65 000
registered refugees living in the camp
primarily from the Eastern DRC
and just a little bit of context here
refugees who are living in nirokusu have
really a lot of restrictions as far as
their Mobility they're not allowed to
leave the camp they also are not able to
work there are a lot of restrictions
they can't get formal employment a lot
of their livelihood opportunities are
really restricted and I think that's
important context when we think about
their risk for both intimate partner
violence and also also mental health
conditions and we'll see how that plays
out in just a minute
So within this context intimate partner
violence or ipv is one of the main
protection priority priorities
recognized by unhcr in the aragusu it's
well kind of acknowledged that it's a
prevalent public health condition
affecting many of the people in this
setting we also know Based on data from
the camp itself but also some more kind
of rigorous data from population-based
surveys surveys in the Eastern DRC where
most of the refugees are from that ipv
is one of the leading risk factors for
poor mental health among women of
reproductive age
so here's some data from this
household-based population-based survey
that was conducted in the Eastern DRC
that shows essentially that women with a
history of ipv have roughly a two-fold
increased likelihood of having
depression PTSD and suicidal ideation or
lifetime attempts you don't see the same
pattern for substance use however I
think it's pretty consistent across a
lot of these other common mental
disorders to see that there's an
increased risk here associated with ipv
So within yaragusu the approach to
addressing these related conditions is
pretty siled so on the one hand we have
the protection actors and in at the time
it was the International Rescue
committee managing a lot of gender-based
violence prevention and response
programs to address ipv
and then we also had some health actors
focused on addressing the mental health
and psychosocial support needs through
the Tanzanian Red Cross
these Services were separated at
multiple levels they were largely siled
and not very well coordinated
so essentially what this means is if say
there's a survivor of ipv with mental
health needs and she goes to the Red
Cross to get Mental Health Care those
services are often not very well
coordinated
to address the gbv or ipv needs as well
so our goal with this study was to see
can we test an integrated intervention
that simultaneously aims to address
intimate partner violence and mental
health in order to improve kind of the
synergies between these two
multi-sectoral approaches
we started off this study by doing some
formative research to understand what
are the Salient mental health and
psychosocial problems affecting
survivors of ipv in Niara Russo and we
use two methods we use free listing
interviews which are a rapid qualitative
method often used to identify a list of
Concepts and prioritize a list of
Concepts or problems in a community
followed by some in-depth informant
interviews to better kind of flesh out
and describe the priority mental health
problems that we identified as affecting
ipv survivors in this context
so the results of this formative
research process revealed really three
key mental health and psychosocial
problems the first was stress or too
many thoughts in Swahili it was
which was really described as those
internalized feelings of distress
and then we had this concept of huzuni
or deep sadness which is more of this
externalized presentation of distress so
feeling really angry or aggressive or
upset
and the third mental health problem that
people described as affecting survivors
of ipv was fear or hope or hofu which
was characterized by worry trembling or
fearing that something bad was going to
happen again
and so these data were really helpful
for us because we were thinking within
the context of an integrated
intervention perhaps the mental health
component could focus on these three
priority mental health conditions
the other part of our formative research
and a really key aspect of this
multi-sectoral process was thinking
about where to position this type of
multi-sectoral intervention within the
refugee camp setting and we went through
a process of community mapping which
first involved like physically mapping
who are the stakeholders involved in
these two activities in mhpss support
and gbv response and where are they
physically located in the camp which is
the map on the left hand side
then we also went through a process of
doing some focus groups with people in
the community with Community Leaders
with humanitarian practitioners to
understand how people navigate these
different systems and services and that
are available to them
and what I think is really interesting
what was super helpful and critical
about this process for us is you can see
on the right hand side in blue are those
kind of formal actors or the formal
system where you have the protection
providers that do the gbv response and
prevention programs like the IRC you
have the police you have case managers
Legal Services Health Services
but what we didn't discover until we did
those focus groups or even from Talking
uh after talking with the humanitarian
actors
um we didn't yet know of this entirely
um this informal system and so
essentially why this is important is
that for ipv survivors it's expected and
really only culturally acceptable for
that problem initially to be aimed to be
resolved within the family and so it's
really looked down upon and there's a
lot of stigma associated with going
directly to that formal system
so most of the survivors of ipv are
still operating within this informal
system of support through the family and
only if the family is not able to
resolve the issue can they start
engaging with neighbors with the local
police force with Village leaders etc
etc
so for us why this was important is that
if we only thought about reaching Women
Within the formal system of care we
would have missed a lot of people who
could potentially benefit from an
integrated mental health and ipv
intervention
please sorry but
the fact that they go first or try to
resolve it into the family isn't that
due also
because of the availability of the other
a more formal services or or more on a
continuous basis
as well it's a great point I yes
certainly I mean there are the access to
Services specifically access to Justice
was really limited so the use of these
local courts and Village leaders was
really essential for that purpose
the way it was described to us primarily
was related to the stigma with actually
seeking Services through the formal
system there were social consequences of
doing that unless it was kind of the
permitted I'd say by some of these
informal actors but certainly access
availability is another challenge as
well
thanks for that question
so with that information we designed
what we called the Google Intervention
Google is the Swahili term for power or
strength it was an eight session
intervention that combined cognitive
processing therapy which is the
psychological intervention designed for
survivors of trauma that fit nicely with
those problem areas we identified in
that informative phase of the research
and we combine cognitive processing
therapy which I should also mention had
been previously tested in the Eastern
DRC so there were some already cultural
adaptation that was done that we felt
needed a great intervention for this
context
and we combined that with advocacy
counseling which is an intervention that
has some evidence for reducing kind of
the chronicity and intensity of ipv
among women who've already experienced
some form of domestic violence
as far as the implementation this photos
a picture of our research and our
intervention counselor so our research
assistants and intervention counselors
in hiragusu after one of our trainings
so we use this task sharing approach
where we hired a team of
volunteers from the community or
incentive workers they were given a very
small incentive to work with the
International Rescue committee to do
some community outreach as part of the
gbv response we worked with this Cadre
of women and trained them in this
intervention so that they could provide
it within these Community settings kind
of integrated within irc's broader gbd
program
the intervention itself involved one
individual session followed by seven
group sessions and again we integrated
it within irc's women's protection and
empowerment program with the intention
of kind of fitting it within us an
existing system of care that women were
already comfortable participating in so
the women's protection and empowerment
program was not specific to gbv it was a
a service that was provided to women it
was not a stigmatizing place for women
to go and if they participated there
they wouldn't necessarily be identified
as someone who was a survivor of ipv
which was a key protection uh concern
for us
and then finally going back to our
discussion around the informal versus
formal systems of care we ended up
recruiting women through community-based
women's groups so that we could reach a
broader number number of women from
Community settings instead of relying
just on those who were accessing
Services through those formal channels
as far as our study design we conducted
a cluster randomized trial where we
randomized those women's groups from
which we recruited to receive these in
Google Intervention or to receive irc's
usual kind of care program for gbb
survivors
and we were specifically looking to
enroll adult
Congolese Refugee women in the arugusu
who reported past year experiences of
ipv and moderate to severe psychological
distress
the outcomes that we measured at
Baseline and then one week after the
intervention so that's about a 10-week
period uh was where anxiety symptoms
depressive symptoms symptoms of
post-traumatic stress disorder and then
the frequency of physical psychological
or sexual ipv
so just to characterize this sample at
Baseline we ended up enrolling 311 women
in the study they were about 33 years of
age on average had lived in nierogusu
for 17 years on average it's a really a
protracted emergency setting a lot of
our research team in fact have been born
within this Camp a lot of people had
lived most of their lives there
um two-thirds of the women in our sample
were married and living with their
current partner
and as far as their mental health this
profile is largely by Design because
they were required to have at least
moderate symptoms of distress in order
to participate but you can see kind of
pretty similar levels of anxiety
depressive and PTSD symptoms that are
between a moderate and a lot of symptoms
over the past two weeks
and what I think is really
um troubling but important is just
looking at the profiles of ipv as well
so the requirement for being eligible
for the study is that they reported
having experienced some form of ipv
within the past year but as you can see
the majority of women who participated
reported having experienced sexual
physical and psychological ipv within
the past year and it was actually quite
rare that women reported not having
experienced sexual violence perpetrated
by an intimate partner
as far as our outcomes so here we
conducted mixed effects models to look
at the difference in change from
Baseline to follow-up between our Google
condition and those who received or were
referred to usual care
and what we ended up seeing is these are
just effect sizes to kind of visualize
the the changes over time we did see
that women who participated in the in
Google Intervention showed significantly
greater reductions in depression anxiety
and PTSD symptoms
we did not see any change or any
significant change as far as ipv between
the usual care and the in Google
condition
I did just want to go on a brief tangent
about measurement of mental health
because I think it is important and
actually one of the most surprising and
interesting findings for me as part of
this study
so one of the things that I mentioned
from the beginning is after having gone
through that formative research process
we decided that those uh three concepts
of distress
tofuazo and huzuni looked roughly like
anxiety depressive PTSD symptoms
and so we perhaps naively selected some
research tools to measure our outcomes
that corresponded to depression anxiety
and PTSD
and so what we did after the fact is we
wanted to say okay let's look and see
how our data cluster together what are
the factors that underlying mental
health conditions and how these symptoms
of mental health problems correlate with
one another
so what I'm showing you on this slide
are
the items so each of those words
corresponds to an item of one of those
measures the gray items corresponding to
depression bread for anxiety purple for
PTSD
and if we did a kind of looked at the
factor structure and if these three
conditions work valid in this context
what we'd expect to see is that the
depression items would be more
correlated or clustered with one another
similarly with the anxiety and with the
PTSD items so we did an exploratory
factor analysis and what we ended up
finding was something more like this
like random mixing of symptoms across
these three conditions that no longer
look like depression anxiety and PTSD
so at first we sat there and we're kind
of stumped we didn't know what to make
of this we tried to say it was just some
strange statistical issue who knows
but after spending some time with this
data what we ended up seeing is that
these problems almost perfectly aligned
with those three initial concepts of
distress that were described To Us by
the women we interviewed in that
formative process
so for me what I take away from this I
mean we know that mental health is
really difficult to measure it's we
don't have gold standards we know
there's cultural variation in how mental
health conditions present but I think
the bigger piece and the bigger picture
here is just the importance of listening
and trying to avoid applying our
perspective and a worldview that's
familiar to us on the data that are
presented because I think perhaps
naively we had done that in the
situation and kind of forced what we
were hearing to fit something that was
familiar when in fact I think we saw
this amazing triangulation of our
qualitative research and our
quantitative research telling us
something quite different
all right so back to the the study and
the uh relation with multi-sectoral
interventions
um I just shared with you the main
results from the study but if we pull
back the curtain a little bit as always
it was a bit Messier there were a lot of
implementation challenges we had a lot
of issues with Staffing and kind of
coordination and organization and all of
these other factors that come up in most
research projects I hope or not I hope
but I bet
um and so we took some time to conduct a
process evaluation to do some interviews
with different stakeholders who
participated in the study those who were
a bit external to the program some focus
group discussions and then we also
collaborated with a group from the
global Health Justice and governance
program at Columbia to do a funding
analysis and look at policy documents at
the same time the study was conducted to
try to understand what factors might
have influenced the implementation
challenges that we faced
and what we came up with was a model
this is a very simplified version of it
the full versions in the paper that you
probably aren't able to read but I'm
happy to share the the slides with you
after
um we came up with a model that
identified multi-layered determinants
that probably looks very similar to the
social ecological model for many of you
that influence the ability to integrate
our gbv and our mental health components
of this intervention
so just to go through these quickly
at the structural level I mentioned at
the very beginning some of these complex
policy policies related to freedom of
movement ability to kind of earn a
living and participate in livelihood
activities
and this policy landscape and the
broader context I think really made it
complex for us to address these related
issues because in many ways those
structural factors really reinforce some
of the risks for both
gbv and mental health problems
we also found a related to your earlier
question that in the legal system there
were a few protections against gbv and
access to Justice was pipe limited there
was a legal officer who would come into
the camp a few times a week to work with
people on cases that it was really
expensive it took a long time there were
a lot of factors that made it hard for
people to access that type of support if
they they wanted to and felt it was
acceptable to do so
um also Mental Health Services were just
limited it was not prioritized
prioritized in the camp there weren't a
lot of resources available to address
mental health needs and I think a lot of
this was ultimately really aggravated by
the funding environment so funding for
gbv and mental health are very separate
and this made it quite challenging for
us to actually convince people funded
from the mental health actors and those
funded by the gbv funders to work
together and to try to achieve kind of
shared or respective goals not to
mention that a lot of the funding
requests were not fulfilled so while gbv
was prioritized the funding was I think
only 40 percent
um or the appeal was only 40 percent
funded and expenditures were half of
what they actually expected so really
under resourced as far as the projected
needs
another challenge at the next level was
just inter-institutional coordination
and I think this is a huge challenge in
the humanitarian sector in general just
coordination across the board
um but surprisingly even between mhpss
and gbb actors
coordination was very limited we found
that there were working groups operating
in the mhpss space and the gbv space who
would say we know the importance of the
other we know that this is related to
what we're doing but there was very
little actual talking or no joint action
plans about how these two sectors and
two areas would work together
we also found that within the gbv plan
it included an element of setting social
support but not really any
operationalization of what that was it
was just this mandator this
recommendation I should say to provide
psychosocial support but with very
little guidance on how to do that
and similarly within the mhpss working
group which was designed to be
multi-sectoral or cross-sectoral the
actors involved were largely working
within the health system as opposed to
engaging with the protection sector
I don't know how to solve this one but
if people have ideas I'd love to hear
them
so at the next level we have the intra
institutional context and this is where
um I think we most acutely saw some of
our challenges within the organization
we were working with there was a really
high rate of Staff turnover at all
levels from headquarters down to the
field staff level and this made it
challenging for us to have kind of
reliable engagement and buy from our
partners because it varied based on
whoever was the decision maker at that
point and I think ultimately made it
really difficult for our counselors to
know
who they were accountable to or what
they were accountable to
another challenge as I mentioned earlier
is that given the siled funding and the
project-based funding that exists in the
humanitarian sector a lot of or the
recognition that it made sense to
integrate mental health and gbv was
often kind of overcome by the need to be
accountable to whatever the objectives
were of a donor funded program and so
there was just a lot of competing
priorities and challenges in terms of
adopting and being more flexible about
this intersectoral approach
and then finally at the community level
I think the the main takeaway for me is
that um
women who participated and the community
more broadly really recognized the value
of bringing this intervention together
that addressed what they referred to as
their home environment their
interpersonal relationships as well as
their minds or their Mental Health
but there was this broad agreement that
it was really insufficient to actually
address the root causes of violence and
many recommendations came up around
providing services to men
engaging incorporating livelihood
opportunities and other factors as well
so some of my key takeaways from this
project which is a really formative
learning experience for me was just the
importance of prioritizing a prevention
approach
um making sure that we're incorporating
considerations for the Social and
contextual determinants of mental health
and of gbv
and also making sure that we are from
the outset promoting engagement and
ownership I think that is so Central to
kind of success in any of these more
complicated types of interventions and
projects
so just before I wrap up I wanted to
highlight just a couple of ongoing
projects that are hopefully building on
some of our lessons learned from the
guru program
so over the past three or four years
I've been working with hias a
humanitarian organization that is
focused on Refugee protection they
provide they have kind of four pillars
they provide legal assistance they do
social protection which includes gbv
prevention and response economic
inclusion and also mental health and
psychosocial support
and over the past few years we've been
working on some projects primarily
focused on providing services for
Venezuelan migrants
many probably in the room know the
economic and political crisis in
Venezuela has led to over 7 million
Venezuelans fleeing the country and over
6 million of those have remained in
Latin America and as you can see here a
lot within Colombia and Peru and in
Ecuador
so our work with ahias has been to work
along key migration routes and to
evaluate the effectiveness and
implementation of community-based
Psychosocial and mental health
interventions that integrate mhpss with
social protection and economic support
for refugees migrants and also host
communities in these various sites in
Latin America
this goes back to this integrated
intervention model and just recognizing
and here are some of the common things
we've heard about in our formative
research around the the drivers and
mental health problems and what those
Salient mental health problems are but
we need to think about these mental
health conditions within the context of
Safety and Security discrimination and
xenophobia social connectedness social
networks and gbv
I also wanted to highlight a few of the
mental health
conditions or constructs that came up in
a lot of our interviews the first one
malastar emotional is it's not I think a
very direct translation but it's the
concept of kind of a poor state of
emotional being which came up repeatedly
in a lot of our different
um
interviews
similarly sadness has come up quite a
bit as has this other construct of Duelo
migratorio which is the concept around
migratory grief and mourning I think
these are really interesting because
again a lot of our mental health
interventions are not really designed to
focus on migration related grief and are
much more I guess optimized to address
some of the more clinical mental health
conditions we're more familiar with
so all of these projects started off
um during covid and so that of course
added another layer to and really
exacerbated a lot of these risk factors
for mental health problems and caused
unique forms of distress as well
here are just some quotes from some of
the qualitative interviews we've done
with migrants in Latin America that I
think really speak to the connection
between mental health challenges and the
pandemic
the first quote is from a mother who
talks about her fear of actually
catching covid and what will happen if
she herself becomes sick and dies
who will ultimately take care of her
children
the middle quote I think is really
interesting because one of the things we
found is a lot of the supports people
have received Venezuelan migrants have
received in Latin America has been
through Community networks and host
communities providing informal supports
to migrants who are arriving
but as this person says during the
pandemic everyone is really stressed and
worried and people were no longer as
willing to help because of the fear that
they had of catching kovid
and then the final quote relates more to
this issue of livelihoods and work
opportunities this comes from a woman in
Panama who talks about how before or now
during the pandemic you can't really
move before you could at least clean
people's houses and now people are
nervous to bring strangers into their
home and so they've now lost another
source of livelihoods there as well
so one study I wanted just to highlight
is um we conducted in Panama and in
Ecuador where really the goal here was
to start off at the very outset of
engaging with communities to design
mental health and psychosocial
intervention combined with a social
protection element to meet the needs of
refugee migrant and host Community women
in three really diverse sites in Latin
America and we intentionally selected
these three different sites in order to
understand what is the role of context
as we think about implementation and the
design of mental health interventions
the first site in is in Panama so Panama
City as well as three communities that
are kind of peri-urban communities
around Panama City that where a lot of
migrants have um have moved
we also worked in tulcan Ecuador which
is on the border with Columbia it's a
pretty remote rural town and often a
Transit point for migrants who are
moving further south
and we also worked in waikil Ecuador
which is a large
City very Urban setting and a
destination for many migrants in Ecuador
or migrants from Venezuela
and as part of this process we went
through a an initial participatory
intervention design uh process so we
started with the similar formative
research that I described in the
previous study where we identified what
are the most Salient outcomes affecting
migrant women in these settings and
those four are listed on your right and
then we ask people what type of
intervention would you like to see to
address these problems and pretty
consistently what we heard is that women
wanted a safe space to come together as
a group to address their needs
and the fun part of all of this is kind
of what happened in the middle and so we
said okay we have this group
intervention that we want to ultimately
improve mental health improve safety
improve connectedness and social support
how would an intervention like this do
that
and through this really iterative and
kind of community-led process we
articulated five key mechanisms that
community members felt like would lead
to these outcomes and those are the five
mechanisms listed here and then the
final step of this process was to say
okay you want to enhance safety and
protection how would you do that what
are some
activities or intervention components
that we can bring into this intervention
in order to activate that mechanism
and the part of this with it was so
interesting is we brought in components
from an evidence-based interventions
existing interventions and kind of
workshopped those with participants but
also had women bring in kind of local
practices and processes that they had
used or they were familiar with in their
cultural context in order to activate
these mechanisms and ultimately kind of
combined and massaged and iterated of
those in order to ultimately arrive at
the entrenosotros intervention
and Trail softress means among or
between us in Spanish it is a
strengths-based intervention that is a
five session weekly intervention that
covers the five topics listed on this
slide
it is delivered by a train a pair of
trained facilitators so community
members many of whom were actually
involved in the intervention design
itself
to groups of women in their communities
this was much more of a mental health
promotion and kind of protection
intervention that it was more of a
clinical one and so we focused this
intervention on women in the community
who had kind of low to moderate levels
of distress
as well and we also ensured that this
intervention was adaptable across each
of our study contexts
so in this study ultimately 225 women
participated in the intervention
um about two-thirds of them were
Venezuelan they were 36 years old on
average about half of them were
unemployed and among those who were
employed most of that was informal labor
it's a really unstable kind of work
situations
and a quarter of those had arrived
within the past year
and then another half I think had
arrived within the past three years
so we looked at their kind of well-being
outcomes a set of selected outcomes that
mapped on to those priority outcomes we
identified through that formative
research process and examine changes
from Baseline to end line which is about
five weeks and then 10 weeks later
and ultimately what we found were
moderate improvements in the positive
mental health outcomes we saw
improvements in psychosocial well-being
community connectedness and sense of
safety
but again we observed this pattern where
people initially get better and then
after the intervention ends they kind of
return toward where they started which
is something we need to figure out as a
field I think
what we didn't see any significant
changes in were more of those
problem-focused outcomes and these are
the outcomes that we often measure in
mental health research things like
distress functioning coping
but what I think was really interesting
here was that the groups that we saw the
greatest Improvement in were those women
who were employed
women who started off a bit worse who
had higher distress or lower well-being
which makes sense and also women who
attended more sessions
the reason I say this is interesting is
I think the employment piece comes out
in two two ways here first we saw that
women who were employed who had more
economic stability responded better to
the intervention they improved at a
greater rate
we also saw that jobs were a barrier to
participation it was women when they
were choosing between whether to to work
that day or come to the intervention of
course they would choose work and so
this made this complicated situation
where we thought the women who could
benefit the most actually had the least
access or ability to participate
and so this has led us to a project
that's just now beginning where we are
now still working in Ecuador with
highest to co-design implementation
strategies to think about how we
integrate an mhpss intervention like the
one I just shared within their economic
services
and we're doing that through the
integrating their mhpss services with an
intervention known as the socioeconomic
Support Program
for those who might be familiar with the
graduation model it's kind of an
abbreviated version of that that starts
by identifying and engaging families
migrant families who are in extreme
poverty providing some basic consumption
support So cash or vouchers for food and
things like that
and then providing training and how to
save money financial literacy skills for
employment
and families enter into what's called an
employment or entrepreneurship school
that provides them with the support and
skills to ultimately start a business or
get a job and we're currently in this
process of like mapping all of the
details of this very complicated
intervention and trying to think about
how and where to integrate those mhpss
supports
all right the last thing I'll just end
with is one more project that actually
ends on Friday
um so these analyzes are literally just
being done as we speak but this is a
project again with hias in Columbia
where now we're trying to understand
what are the relative
effects of different integration
multi-sectoral integration approaches as
far as implementation and Effectiveness
outcomes
so here we're working with a scalable
intervention developed by the World
Health Organization known as problem
management Plus or PM Plus in its group
format and this is an intervention
that's had a large growing evidence base
it's based on cognitive behavioral
therapy and a lot of some of the common
kind of problem-solving skills that are
Central to a lot of mental health
interventions
and what we're testing like I said are
two models of how to integrate this
intervention within Protection Services
community-based Protection Services
we're working in three communities in
the button Kia area of in Northern
Colombia where a lot of migrants have
settled
and the first condition we're comparing
is what I'll refer to as the traditional
task sharing model and so in this model
we have a psychologist or a mental
health specialist
who trains and supervises a group of
we'll say non-specialist people without
formal Mental Health Training to deliver
this intervention
and the people we've decided to train
are similar to the Google program
they're Community women from the
community who are working with highest
and serving as kind of social promoters
of protection services they kind of
serve as a liaison between highest in
the community do community outreach and
provide kind of some basic services and
supports at the community level
and so in our first phase of this
project we trained a group of I think
six to eight uh social or Community
promoters to provide this intervention
to groups of women in their community
and I'll consider this kind of a partial
integration model because it still has
some Reliance on that mental health
specialist to provide that training and
supervision
so in many ways it's still expensive it
still might not be as scalable because
it still requires the time energy and
salary of a full-time psychologist in
order to implement this model
the second condition for the study is
what we called the cascading cash
sharing model and so here were further
decentralizing a lot of the roles and
activities of the psychologists to
community members and this is what uh
we're also calling more full integration
of mhpss into the community-based
protection system
so in this model what we found is or
what we did is we had a psychologist
train a group of the women we had
trained in the initial phase to actually
be trainers and supervisors themselves
and then those Community promoters
trained a new group of women who are
Community promoters to provide the
intervention to other women in their
community
and served as kind of trainers and
supervisors throughout that whole
process and so while the psychologist is
still a piece of this they're not
requiring or not providing
that regular weekly supervision and
support but rather I'm more of a kind of
consultative basis
so what we found and again these are
very very preliminary results
um so we did observe just between people
who received the intervention and those
who did not we did observe an additional
or excuse me an initial a reduction in
depressive symptoms during the
intervention period but again we still
see that kind of regression back toward
Baseline which is something that is
important for us to Grapple with
but what I think is the really exciting
finding here is when we compare those
two implementation strategies those two
models of integration we actually see
very similar patterns as far as
depression outcomes where the
trajectories of depression among people
who received the intervention from from
Community promoters trained by
Specialists was very similar to people
who received the intervention from
Community promoters who were trained and
supervised by other community promoters
so that fully integrated
community-based protection model
our preliminary results also suggest
that we see comparable Fidelity and
competencies among our providers between
these two study conditions which I think
is quite promising
so just as far as conclusions I think
there's still a lot to learn but I think
what we have slowly been learning along
the way is that integrating mhpss into
other sectors like protection like
livelihoods seems to be quite relevant
to the needs of these communities
we also can see that it's feasible to do
that while there are all of these
challenges I shared with funding and
organizational mandates and all of these
other factors it does appear that it is
feasible for us to design and integrate
these Services as long as we
meaningfully engage and kind of
co-design these approaches with people's
representatives from other sectors
and we have some preliminary evidence
that the quality and effectiveness of
these mental health interventions can be
maintained when we integrate them within
other sectors and that we don't kind of
dilute the mental health effects by
transitioning them into other sectors
and spaces and systems
there's still a lot we need to know like
how do we actually sustain the benefits
of these interventions how do we
reconceptualize these interventions so
they might not be kind of a
insular process but we can provide some
ongoing support to people to maintain
those benefits
how do we think about the kind of
structural and inter-institutional
determinants which we haven't really
captured here
there's a lot we still need to know and
a lot of questions which is why I would
like to end by saying thank you so much
for your time and I'd love to hear your
thoughts and questions going forward
um I will just say also big thanks to
our teams these are some photos from our
different research teams on these
projects and for me by far the best part
of this work is building relationships
and the collaboration so I can't thank
these people enough thank you
question on on Zoom from Melody so she
was asking
um if if you know
um what is the reason or if you can
speculate why in the Google
study you would see such a high staff
turnover
so that's a good question so I think
we saw a high staff torn over at
multiple levels I actually so
as far as the staff at kind of the the
people most involved in implementation
were our facilitators so the counselors
we trained the main cause of turnover
there was actually resettlement which is
a good reason or turnover to happen
there was active resettlement happening
at the beginning stages of the project
that was actually the largest reason
that participants dropped out of the
program as well
but at slightly higher levels in Cafe
and I were talking about this earlier I
think it is really hard to do this work
and I think in a place like narabusu a
really protracted complex context a lot
of the
staff kind of the field staff are really
burnt out and so you saw a lot of
turnover people moving between sites
that was quite common unfortunately we
also saw that at the higher levels one
of our initial Partners on the project
had another job opportunity and so
ultimately left the organization and
that I think happened less frequently
but it was pretty
um had a pretty big impact on our
program because I think she was really
the champion of this approach within her
organization at the headquarters level
so I think there are a lot of reasons
for turnover but I think it's it's
really hard work and common to see these
levels of turnover at the field staff
level yeah
um I just had a question similarly about
the Google Intervention and that in the
end that you found that it was better to
organize to not organize outcomes or
depressive symptoms or these symptoms
via you know PTSD depression anxiety but
rather Whole Foods uni and the third I
just don't want to butcher that one
um I'm wondering moving forward how do
you if you wanted to examine any other
kind of conditions in relation to mental
health like would you use that as the
reference and then essentially how do
you use that moving forward as your
measurement I know because it's probably
going to going to change not only across
different populations but also over time
too you know
um it's a really good question we
grapple there's a paper we published on
this I'm glad you're asking about this
because surprisingly it's one of the
things I'm still fascinated by was that
that finding or that kind of
triangulation of information
um
one of the ways that we've thought about
this in our group is I think there is
still value in using
measures across multiple contexts for
comparison's sake but I think we need to
be more deliberate about incorporating
items that reflect local concepts of
distress
so there's been some work by Emily
Harris and others um who have like
looked mapped to all of like the
depression measures across the world and
how they've been used and identified
some unique items across different
contexts and so one of the strategies
they suggest is try to find like a core
set of items that you think are helpful
to measure across multiple studies and
across populations but through this
formative research process Identify some
items that are missing that you can then
kind of integrate into your measures
um I don't know that I would recommend
unless I was working in the very same
context and could have could validate
that these three
concepts of distress were still
appropriate I wouldn't necessarily take
those three idioms and apply them in
different places right because I don't
think they're Universal or even kind of
static I think they these things are
fluid and quite Dynamic so we have to
kind of think more flexibly about how we
design our measures to enable both of
those
comparisons does that
this is like very applicable to my work
and that you might find for instance uh
that somebody else has used
um pcl5 or the travel questionnaire in
that country but essentially what you're
arguing is like yeah I might work at
this level but if you really want to get
a more accurate estimate it's
incorporating kind of that variation
that's based off cultural or you know
the local context interpretation of
these conditions totally yeah and I
think I mean one of the things that's
hard too it's like when we looked at the
before we did that exploratory factor
analysis and just allowed the items to
correlate as they may if you did look at
things like internal consistency and the
confirmatory factor analysis like how
well did the data fit depression anxiety
and PTSD
and there were no like major red flags
but it did seem that after doing this
EFA approach that actually the data fit
the concepts we heard about in a
formative research much better or more
naturally perhaps and so I think
even if something has been validated
elsewhere I think it's always still good
for you to kind of explore what is
missing and how can we think about
balancing those two approaches
I have two questions related to the
communities response to these mental
health interventions the first one is I
guess on how the people perceive these
interventions to be effective or not and
um especially coming in I guess as
people from the Northern or more
developed countries
um are there any instances on risk of
cultural appropriation of what mental
health issues were in the local context
especially in I guess among some of the
refugee communities patriarchy might be
a lot more of an issue and certain
practices they they have is not it's
quite foreign to us so I think that's
the first question and how you're able
to navigate that well
try to measure mental health conditions
and the second one is on I guess once
interviews end what is that transition
process like and how is the community
able to I guess
um move forward with it or continue to
benefit from it even if programs and I
love both of these questions
um so taking the first one I mean I
think
the question around
like how communities respond I think is
one that is
I've evolved or thought differently
about over time and it's really kind of
what I've used as kind of my guide in
thinking about
future projects and steps I mean
I think It ultimately comes down to
where who's making who has the
decision-making power in in what the
intervention looks like and how it's
tested and evaluated I think one of with
the example I gave from Ecuador and
Panama where we kind of said like okay
the design the intervention based on
what fits will offer some ideas but
the community really did design that I
think there are a lot of people who are
very skeptical about that approach
because there is this interesting debate
I think in the field right now between
like the
um
clothing kind of true or kind of
maintaining the
Fidelity to what we have evidence for
and relaxing that toward more of a kind
of cultural relativistic approach and I
have swung a little bit more in that
direction recently and and think that
we have kind of the potential to do less
harm by transitioning some of that
decision-making power to the community
themselves and I think the
like is this that intervention as
effective as something else I'm not sure
one of the things that I didn't actually
mention here is part of that study
design we integrated One external
component and did kind of a comparative
effectiveness trial comparing two
versions of the intervention one that
was enhanced with this who intervention
and one was that was the community
design version alone and we actually
found there was only one indication that
there was any differences in there and
how people responded to them or people's
trajectories as far as their outcomes so
I think this is a big debate at the
moment but I guess I am leaning toward
if you enable and facilitate the
decision-making power to happen within
communities I think
I think you run less of a risk of some
of the points that you brought up but it
is
if there's a lot of debate on that topic
your question around sustainability is
also a really good one
um so the very the final project that I
mentioned the one in Columbia where we
kind of trained these different groups
of providers and counselors and trainers
and supervisors the feedback we got at
the very end so we did he had some focus
groups with our counselors and our
trainers and supervisors to say like
to get their feedback but also to go
through this sustainability planning
process excuse me
um where we actually asked them like
what would you need to sustain this
program is it money is it space what
like what would that look like to you
and how would you design this going
forward and it was interesting and we're
actually thinking of talking with the
donor about this for the next the next
stage or the next version iteration of
that project
where what the community wanted was some
kind of formalized process of seeing
themselves as a community-based
organization
and so which I thought was really
interesting because in some ways
um
providing the skills and the
infrastructure for them to organize and
be seen as kind of this entity within
the community that has the set of skills
and that they can then kind of Leverage
in different ways with the government or
with different organizations I think is
really powerful and so that's actually
what we're thinking at this stage is how
can we better facilitate that
organization and mobilization of these
women into groups that can then kind of
sustain the project in the longer term
but I think there are not a lot of good
examples of
of sustainment of these types of
interventions for the reasons you're
probably alluding to
additional questions here
um
do you want to ask the questions
and otherwise I'll just read so she says
that if you would share some details of
about how GPM plus participants were
selected and how groups were formed and
Did women know each other and if they
knew or did not each other do you think
if it influences the
impact on the intervention good question
and yes I rushed through that example so
didn't go through those details so the
for the last setting up with the group
PM Plus model there were selection
criteria to identify women who are
experiencing some level a moderate level
of distress and functional impairment as
well the women identified actually came
through two sources one was people women
who had sought support through highest
and then highest referred them to the
program the other was through the
facilitators or the counselors
themselves so them kind of referring
women to highest so that they could
participate and so it was kind of too
prone as far as through the humanitarian
organization as well as through the
community the second part of that
question
was oh about how women the groups were
formed so the groups were formed within
those three communities they were kind
of far apart from each other and so it
is likely
um that women knew each other or some
women might have known each other
beforehand I don't think that was the
case all the time we're still analyzing
our qualitative data which is where we
would be able to answer that more
directly so I can't say for sure but
what I will say is actually from the
name Google Intervention initially we
had assumed that it was better to keep
groups separate not to have kind of
friends or people who knew each other in
the same groups especially when talking
about ipv and what we found I guess
was the opposite that women actually
wanted to kind of maintain their
existing networks when they participated
in the intervention the exception being
is if there were was some sort of
generational difference so women did not
want to be younger women did not want to
be in the same group as an older woman
for cultural reasons
um and so we had to stratify the groups
by age but also it was actually
preferred for women from the same
women's groups to participate in groups
together
that answers the question right and
there is another question from uh Lami
so first she thank you for the great
work and presentation and then she said
if you can get some the thought as the
best practices and your recommendation
as to how to evaluate the added value of
multi-sexual interventions that
integrates mental help with other
services included cash transfer in
humanitarian settings
that's also a really good question so
based with my collaborators at highest
they actually just formed a working
group through the iasc the interagency
standing committee on mhpss mhpss cash
and livelihoods so I think there's a lot
of energy and focus on kind of
understanding
how to integrate but as far as how to
evaluate I think the next big step is
thinking about
um is mapping and evaluating outcomes
both economic and mental health outcomes
and determining whether that integration
actually
improves those outcomes synergistically
more than we would see if they were
operating independently it's a big
project I think that's hoping where we
hope to go with this project in Ecuador
but I think that's a ways down the line
um
the second part of that question in
addition to evaluating was did I guess
something
um uh yeah basically yeah integrated
with the cash transfers in humanity
currency so
this is Dr Joe malamis the one who just
asked the question about the integration
um Dr Green I really appreciate your
thoughts and the reason I was asking
about the recommendations because you
said it it can be rather messy to work
um with the integration of services and
sometimes just getting the Buy in and
the reason why I'm asking that is
because we're trying to do this work in
Lebanon with Syrian refugees in Lebanese
host communities and one of the major
challenges is sometimes you have a
combination of things going on we have
some services that are already
integrated and nobody is doing any
evaluation and it's kind of some form of
integration and then some that are
looking at it and kind of thinking why
why they added
you know uh challenges and barriers and
let alone also the identity of the
refugees that take the cash transfers
that may not want to be known for the
mental health and vice versa so I guess
the the question was really
multi-folded is one how do you overcome
those challenges to to get the buy-in
for those different services to talk to
each other and to do that and when it
comes to evaluation and maybe this is a
conversation Beyond today but I just
yeah I wanted those thoughts about the
kind of behind the curtain yeah and I'd
love to talk more so please please reach
out I think
it's as you're saying this I mean it's
funny because like one of the challenges
that we've had in our our early attempts
to do this is to actually get even
within the same organization the
economics team and the mhpss team to
speak the same language and it's I think
ultimately what I've arrived at is I
think a big takeaway for me is ensuring
that at every stage in these projects
making sure there's kind of equal
representation across sectors from the
design through the implementation
through the evaluation so that you kind
of are aligned throughout the entire
process but as you're talking about
evaluation it reminds me one of the
the things that we've come up against is
even just the way we operationalize some
of the key outcomes so for example
the economics team one of their main
outcomes of this intervention is
community integration promoting
Community integration through this
economics and livelihoods intervention
and so we've been trying to figure out
between the mhpss team and economics
team how do we measure that and what
we've discovered is actually our kind of
the root of what we think Community
integration is is totally different and
this comes down to a conversation we had
even about social support where the
economics team has really been focused
around instrumental support how many
people do you have in your network who
can provide a loan if you need if you
need cash for something versus the more
traditional mental health intervention
is like how many people do you have to
talk to or support you when you're
having trouble with something and so I
think even just aligning the with what
we're evaluating as far as our outcomes
across sectors can be quite challenging
the other thing that we've kind of come
up against that might be less complex
with cash than some of the other
interventions is just
the complexity of mental health
interventions and the economics
interventions make it really I think
hard for us to isolate impacts right and
also when we're thinking about to your
point around participation
all of the people participating in an
economics intervention might not be
appropriate for the same type of type of
mental health intervention and so how do
we think about like what are we really
evaluating then
um so I think it's quite complicated and
something we haven't fully navigated
ourselves yet but I'd love to to chat
more as you're grappling with this as
well thanks for the question
there is a question by Charles
do you want to ask thank you thank you
Professor Green I think this is really
super important work and it's right on
The Cutting Edge of Mental Health and
Social cycle social support and
localization and I'm a sociologist and
I've been nine months into 12 months of
ethnographic work asking mental health
workers about how they're localizing
their work and the struggles that they
face as they're working with refugees in
spaces and I think what you're saying
about like having these initial
assessments about the drivers of mental
health and how they should be culturally
situated is super awesome and I think
it's becoming more common but the the
examples that you gave in Panama and
Ecuador were the actual interventions
are culturally based I think that's
still something that there's a lot of
space to do a lot of growth I know like
rack IRC and a lot of other
organizations are all kind of using the
same interventions
um so when I talk to these kind of small
and medium-sized organizations
um and the people who are working within
them they have a lot of struggle because
these workers are really dedicated to
supporting refugees
um but then when they're trying to
localize the work it's they don't know
what to do with their expertise right so
their their mental health and
psychosocial support exports right but
if the intervention should be locally
based and ones that are determined by
the Target community
they don't know they are they just
creating space right or or do they
actually have an expertise that they're
bringing to the table but then they can
you know talk about what the refugee
community so I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit about
how people who are struggling with the
localization of these programs want to
do such good work
how do you see the line of like where
your expertise comes in whether it's
just a political project of creating
space for people alongside giving them
living support things like that so it
seems like a complicated normative space
I was just wondering if you thought
about that and any ex advice you could
give these experts
advice
um yeah that's a good question thanks
for those thoughts I mean I yeah I mean
all right so our partners I guess my
closest Partners in both Ecuador and
Panama are themselves psychologists but
they come from the world of community
psychology which is a discipline that
I'm not as familiar with here in the US
but I think is something that is much
more robust in in Latin America for
example and I think more amenable to
some of these I guess more collaborative
approaches to designing and thinking
about mental health interventions
I mean I well I guess the
discomfort with deviating from kind of
what is evidence-based or what we think
is evidence-based for me I think the
role maybe of the specialist is to is
first to just making sure that the
interventions themselves are safe and
we're not kind of creating a situation
that could lead to harm
um I think that is kind of Paramount and
kind of a good starting point for their
role and something that these people
have the expertise to do and the
knowledge
um I mean I think a lot of it and this
is a challenge I've been talking a lot
with highest about is like these
formative phases take a year and it's a
lot of building relationships and a lot
of building trust and sometimes
humanitarian organizations don't have
that luxury of taking a year to go
through this process but I think the
benefit and where we got was a really
nice place where it was an exchange
between the community and the
psychologists and the our team that felt
really horizontal I think it felt really
like they were collaboratively working
toward an intervention together as
opposed to taking something and tweaking
it to fit here and there which I think
is what happens in a lot of adaptations
um
but I think it takes time and so I don't
know what the solution is in a context
where you don't have that luxury I think
that is
that is tricky yeah I don't know if I
have an answer for you on that but I
think that there still is a very
valuable role of Specialists and kind of
being facilitators and guides and
providing being part of the having a
seat at the table but not necessarily
driving it
yeah that's great thank you yeah happy
to talk more too Professor Claire green
thank you so much that was a great
question